now you might find this interesting i i
was wondering
um how is right-wing media going to spin
the violent riotous insurrection that
took place in washington dc yesterday
uh will they say it was actually antifa
and black lives matter
the answer is yes some of them did and
i'll have clips of that for you a little
bit later
how are they going to frame what is a
rift
to some degree between trump and much of
the rest of the republican party for
example i put the tweet up on the screen
for
you earlier which has since been removed
by twitter
of donald trump denouncing his own vice
president mike pence
where he said mike pence failed us and
and i am not aware and was not able to
find
in the historical record for the last
150 years a president
denouncing his own vice president in
this way i just wasn't able to find it
how would right-wing media deal with
that i have one example for you
and it is uh it's almost
poetically just that it comes from fox
and friends host ainsley earhart who has
been
one of the most sycophantic and vile
brown-nosers
of this president for four years i hope
you're sitting down for this
ainsley earhart's framing was
i hope donald trump can
forgive mike pence for not trying to
overthrow the election results
think about that okay donald trump
demanded that mike pence do
uh the the impossible and the illegal
and the immoral which is
somehow stopped joe biden from being
president despite that being the will of
the people
and then denounced his own vice
president
after this uh violent insurrection
started
ainsley's idea is i really hope
trump will forgive pence take a look at
this video clip
you know what mike pence can just wave
that magic wand
it'll all be fixed i hope that doesn't
taint their relationship because they
have been such
supporters of one another and been a
good team because
donald trump how can it be good after
that i'm sure it won't be but i hope
that
you know i hope the president will be
able to forgive him because mike pence
is such a
a stellar individual his walk with god
is amazing i mean he's
he's a good man and um you know both of
them have done
a lot to help the country and i hope
that they can move forward and move past
this and just agree that there were
there were differences
i'm sure the president feels like um i'm
responsible for him becoming vice
president so he should have done this
for me but the president as you've been
saying all along brian
um the vice president has stood by his
side and supported him all along the way
so hopefully uh their friendship won't
end after this for
the good of the country i bet you it's
done yeah i know so
this is weaponized delusion
and we're going to have i couldn't
possibly get all of these clips for you
now
this this is this is one type of
reaction which is a complete
reframing it's like the equivalent of a
lot of it's a trapeze artist
flipping around and turning everything
upside down and swinging wildly
from one place to another some other
networks and some other channels and
outlets were sort of pretending none of
this was going on
even fox news at one point yesterday
five hours into the riot essentia
insurrection if you went to the fox news
website
all that all it said was uh protesters
delay
counting of electoral votes which
if you had been paying attention does
not exactly capture the violence
and and seditious nature of what was
going on yesterday
others uh for example newsmax and oan
for much of the day
were just talking about completely
different things altogether it was like
nothing is going on
at one point last night in fact when the
electoral vote count continued
uh most cable networks were covering it
but if you turn to fox news it was laura
ingraham
ranting about how maybe it was actually
antifa
who did this in washington dc and i'll
get to those clips a little bit later so
as i said on yesterday's show different
people deal with loss
in different ways uh but what is
abundantly clear
is that there there is nothing too crazy
there is nothing that these trump
supporters can do
that won't find some defense in some
right-wing media
and there is no absurdity too absurd
that someone on fox news won't be able
to come up with some kind of pretzel
logic pretzel i hope trump forgives
pence pence is disgusting
but at least pence immediately denounced
the violence
full stop reportedly as the guy who
actually called the national guard
to get to dc even though donald trump
was resisting doing it
and immediately came back and said
let's continue we're not going to be
delayed from doing this
pence is horrible his failures on
coronavirus his religious nuttery i mean
he's he's horrible but the idea that
trump needs to forgive
pence uh if this is any indication of
what fox news is going to look like for
the next two or four years
we are really in for it and after the
break we will get to yes
the idea that what could it have been
antifa that actually did the pro-trump
insurrectionist mob yesterday
we'll get to that a little bit later